[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich mache heute eine Tarte,
eine Lebkuchen-Tarte.
Ich weiß nicht. Es fiel mir irgendwie so ein.
Und ich möchte mich so ein bisschen
an diesen gefüllten Lebkuchenherzchen da orientieren.
Weil die esse ich echt supergerne.
Und deswegen gibt es heute eine Lebkuchen-Tarte.
Als Basis dient ein Lebkuchenteig,
– okay, das war jetzt logisch –
so Gingerbread-Teig.
Und da mache ich jetzt eine doppelte Portion.
Denn ich möchte daraus noch
kleine Lebkuchenmännchen und Herzchen und Sternchen
eben noch ausstechen.
Dann habe ich nämlich gleich auch was zum Dekorieren
und auch direkt den Teig für die Tarte.
Dafür nehme ich
100 Gramm weiche Butter,
220 Gramm Honig,
120 Gramm Zucker,
600 Gramm Mehl,
etwas Salz
und Backpulver.
Hier habe ich das Lebkuchengewürz,
Kakao
und ein Ei.
Zuerst nehme ich jetzt die Butter.
Die kommt in den Topf.
Dazu der Honig.
Der bringt ja diesen typischen Lebkuchengeschmack
auch mit rein, muss man sagen.
Dann den Zucker dazu.
Und die Zutaten
– ups!
Und die Zutaten dann schön einmal aufkochen lassen.
So schmilzt die Butter und der Zucker löst sich auf
und der Honig verbindet sich wundervoll.
Schön wird das.
[Musik]
Die Zutaten jetzt einfach kurz aufkochen lassen,
damit sich der Zucker schön auflöst.
[Musik]
Wenn die Masse aufkocht,
dann direkt vom Herd herunternehmen
und in eine große Rührschüssel füllen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier das Mehl mit dem Backpulver vermischen.
Kakao noch mit rein.
Lebkuchengewürz.
Wenn ihr kein Lebkuchengewürz dahabt,
könnt ihr das auch gerne selbst zusammenmischen
und zum Beispiel Zimt und Ingwer, Nelken, Kardamom,
also alles, was ihr gerne habt, hier mit hineingeben.
Da ist auch jedes Gewürz so ein bisschen anders gemischt.
Und jetzt mache ich es an besten so, dass ich
immer nach und nach
Mehl dazu gebe.
Und sobald ich ein bisschen Mehl dabei habe,
kann ich auch das Ei reingeben.
Denn jetzt wäre die Masse einfach noch zu heiß
und das Ei würde sofort gerinnen.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Sobald sich alles verbunden hat,
ist der Teig fertig.
So sieht der Teig jetzt aus.
Er ist auch noch sehr warm und auch klebrig.
Den fülle ich jetzt hier rein, decke ihn ab
und lasse ihn dann erst mal ruhen,
so für etwa eine halbe Stunde bis Stunde.
Das muss jetzt auch gar nicht im Kühlschrank sein.
Er darf in den Kühlschrank,
aber, wenn ihr es in den Kühlschrank stellt,
dann ist er später sehr kalt
und ihr müsst ihn eben noch mal ordentlich weich kneten.
Aber Hauptsache,
er bekommt jetzt ein bisschen Zeit zum Ruhen.
Aber ich stelle ihn in den Kühlschrank.
Da geht es schneller.
Denn, Sarah, wir haben gelernt,
im Kühlschrank werden Dinge schneller kalt.
>> SARAH: Hm.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: So.
Jetzt den Teig nach der Kühlzeit einfach noch mal durchkneten
und dann ausrollen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier diese 5-mm-Abstandsringe.
Dann wird es schön gleichmäßig.
Mh. Ich brauche doch ein bisschen mehr.
Ich habe jetzt hier noch was übrig.
Denn ich habe ja etwas mehr,
damit ich noch Gingerbread-Männer und eben auch
kleine Herzchen und Sternchen ausstechen kann.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich jetzt hier meine Tarteform.
Das ist die mittlere, die 25er.
Die fette ich jetzt mit etwas Backtrennspray.
Dann den Teig kurz aufrollen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie rissig er ist.
Ja, es geht ganz gut.
Schön reinlegen.
Und dann hier den Rest
einfach mit der Palette nach außen hin wegstreichen.
[Musik]
Und aus dem Rest Teig werde ich jetzt gleich noch,
wie gesagt, Gingerbread-Männer,
Herzchen und Sterne ausstechen.
Aber ich kann jetzt hier schon mal
den Tarteboden einmal vorbacken.
Dann mache ich hier noch die Kekse.
Und dann kümmere ich mich um die Füllung.
[Musik]
Die Kekse mache ich jetzt dünner.
Die mache ich jetzt nur 3 mm dick.
Zum einen habe ich dann mehr
und zum anderen sind sie nicht so dick.
Ja, ich glaube, für die Kekse
und für die Deko ist es dann auch schöner.
[Musik]
Was hier beim Keksbacken wirklich wichtig ist:
Wenn ihr so kleine Elemente habt
wie diese kleinen Sternchen,
dann kommen die auf ein Blech,
so große Elemente auf ein anderes Blech.
Denn, wenn ihr jetzt so einen minikleinen Stern
hier mit dazu gebt,
dann wird der Stern einfach zu lange gebacken,
weil die großen Gingerbread-Männer
natürlich zu lange brauchen oder länger brauchen.
Daher immer einfach
gleich große Plätzchen auf ein Blech geben.
Und dann habt ihr eben auch die gleiche Backzeit.
Und dann ist jeder Keks gleichmäßig durch
und keiner zu gar und keiner noch zu roh.
[Musik]
Was ich vielleicht noch sagen sollte:
Verwendet beim Ausrollen wirklich kaum oder gar kein Mehl.
Am Anfang habe ich es jetzt auch ein bisschen gebraucht,
gegen Ende so gar nicht mehr.
Und das ist jetzt der Rest, den ich noch habe.
Denn, wenn ihr zu viel Mehl einarbeitet,
dann passiert es einfach,
dass der Teig zu trocken wird und brüchig wird.
Und auch bei ganz normalen Ausstecherle-Plätzchen
wirklich kein Mehl benutzen oder ganz wenig
oder Bäckerstärke auch nur ganz wenig.
Guckt mal. Und dann
rolle ich den Rest einfach immer wieder zusammen
und kann praktisch den kompletten Teig aufbrauchen
bis zum letzten Ende.
Und dann habt ihr nichts, was weggeschmissen wird.
So. Schaffe ich noch ein Sternchen?
Schaffe ich noch eins?
Nee, aber ein Herz.
Ta-daa!
Und das bisschen esse ich.
Jetzt ist er leer.
Übrigens ist mittlerweile auch die Tarte vorgebacken.
Sie ist noch
recht heiß.
Schaut mal.
So sieht sie aus.
Die lasse ich kurz abkühlen
und kann mich in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal um die Füllung kümmern.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Havuç.
>> SALLY: Danke!
>> SARAH: Bitte, gerne.
>> SALLY: Brauchen wir die für die Tarte?
>> SARAH: Nee.
Das ist so Vitamine für zwischendurch.
>> SALLY: Vitamine.
>> SARAH: Hier, Josh.
Ich habe dir auch eine Havuç geschält.
>> JOSH: Danke.
>> SALLY: Havuç!
[Musik]
Okay.
Ich habe ja gesagt,
ich habe mich so ein bisschen orientiert
an diesen Lebkuchenherzchen.
Und deswegen gibt es zum einen eine fruchtige Füllung.
Ich hoffe, es klappt so.
Ich habe hier einfach Johannisbeergelee.
Und dieses Johannisbeergelee wird kurz erwärmt
in einem Topf, damit es wieder flüssig wird.
Ich überlege gerade.
Vielleicht binde ich das ein bisschen mit Stärke,
damit es...
Oh, ich habe so ein bisschen Angst,
dass es beim Backen so richtig flüssig wird
und dann sich so vermischt.
Aber ich hätte es gern...
Ich mache ein bisschen Stärke rein.
So spontan.
Also ich habe hier mein Johannisbeergelee,
einen Teelöffel Stärke.
Das wird jetzt kurz verrührt
und das kann ich einmal aufkochen lassen.
Und dann könnt ihr schon mal einen Teller vorbereiten,
der etwas kleiner ist als eure Tarteform.
Schaut mal hier.
Ich habe jetzt hier so ein Emailleteller, den kleinen.
Der passt hier perfekt rein.
Und die Rundung ist ja noch mal kleiner.
Also er muss einfach ein bisschen kleiner sein.
Und dann, denke ich,
wird das gut.
Das muss jetzt einmal aufkochen,
damit die Stärke auch binden kann.
[Musik]
Ups!
Ja, vielleicht hätte man einen größeren Topf verwenden sollen.
Na ja.
Einmal aufgekocht, Ziel erreicht, alles gut.
>> JOSH: Einmal übergekocht.
>> SALLY: Einmal übergekocht.
Egal.
Okay.
Das kommt jetzt kurz ins Gefrierfach,
damit es wirklich komplett einmal einfriert.
Und ich zeige euch gleich die Zutaten für die Schokocreme.
Dafür nehme ich 400 Gramm Sahne.
Dann habe ich hier 200 Gramm Zartbitterkuvertüre
und 100 Gramm Vollmilchkuvertüre,
ein Ei,
eine Prise Salz
und eine Prise Zimt
und 30 Gramm Butter.
Zimt könnt ihr natürlich optional dazu verwenden.
Ihr könnt auch Vanille verwenden oder Tonka Wonka.
Aber ich denke, dass so eine Schoko-Zimt-Füllung
ganz gut mit rein passt.
Die Sahne wird jetzt kurz aufgekocht in einem Topf.
[Musik]
Und...
Oh, Leben am Limit.
Richtig Leben am Limit!
Sobald die Sahne kocht,
kommt die Kuvertüre mit rein.
Und ich bin ja eigentlich
nicht so der Fan von Vollmilchkuvertüre, aber
hier in dem Fall bringt sie einfach die nötige Süße mit rein,
weil Zartbitterkuvertüre eben nicht so ganz süß ist.
Das heißt, wenn ihr es herber haben wollt, dann
nehmt gerne nur Zartbitterschokolade.
Zack, zack, zack.
>> JOSH: Kann man da auch Nougat einrühren?
>> SALLY: Ich wusste es.
Ja, ihr könnt auch Nougat einrühren.
Ich habe mir noch überlegt,
ob ich nicht Nougat nehmen soll statt Vollmilch
für dich.
>> JOSH: Also, wenn ich nachher ein Stück probiere,
esse ich Nougat dazu.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Dann darfst du Nougat dazu essen.
Was ich jetzt machen werde, ist Folgendes.
Damit die Masse jetzt schnell abkühlt,
möglichst schnell,
fülle ich sie hier rein,
weg aus dem heißen Topf.
Ui!
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui!
Leckerschmecker!
[Musik]
Dann lasse ich das jetzt kurz abkühlen.
Die Fruchtfüllung im Gefrierfach kühlt ja auch noch ab.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder,
wenn das hier einfach so
entweder schon ganz abgekühlt ist, bei Raumtemperatur,
oder einfach nur noch lauwarm.
Das passt dann auch.
Aber die Fruchtfüllung sollte auf jeden Fall eingefroren sein.
Die könnt ihr auch gerne zuallererst machen.
Aber die Idee kam mir halt erst so währenddessen.
Ich habe eine gute und eine schlechte Nachricht.
Mh.
Die gute zuerst:
Die Schokoladensahne ist abgekühlt.
Die schlechte ist:
Die Marmelade ist nicht gefroren,
obwohl das jetzt echt zwei Stunden im TK war fast, gell?
Eine Stunde? Zwei?
Also es ist eiskalt.
Aber egal.
Ich gucke gleich spontan, was wir machen.
Jetzt kann ich hier schon mal die Creme verrühren.
Also einmal die Schokosahne.
Hätte ich jetzt echt nicht erwartet.
Ich müsste mal gucken.
Vielleicht lag es auch am Bindemittel, was im Gelee drin ist.
Ich glaube, die werden ja oft mit Pektin gebunden
oder mit Agar Agar.
Aber eigentlich dürfte es echt kein Problem sein.
Na ja,
hätte ich vielleicht doch so eine normale Fruchteinlage
wie immer machen sollen, mit Agar Agar kochen.
Egal.
Es wird schon klappen.
Okay.
Hier habe ich jetzt die Schokosahne.
Ich gebe das Ei dazu.
Es hat jetzt auch die perfekte Temperatur,
weil das Ei so jetzt eben
nicht direkt flockt und bindet und gerinnt.
Das erinnert jetzt ein bisschen an den Mississippi Mud Pie.
Ich gebe jetzt hier noch die weiche Butter dazu.
Die darf auch gern flüssig sein.
Salz und Zimt.
[Musik]
Okay, Josh. Bist du eher so der Sicherheitstyp
oder eher so der "No risk, no fun"?
>> JOSH: No risk, no fun.
>> SALLY: Also dann probieren wir es mit der Fruchteinlage.
Ich meine, sie ist ja nicht flüssig.
Sie ist halt nur so
klitschig.
Ich weiß nur noch nicht, wie ich sie da reinkriege.
Ich drehe einfach die Folie drüber um.
Komm, mittiger, mittiger.
Ups!
Und wenn sie jetzt abgeht, dann ist es gut.
Wenn nicht, dann
habe ich ein Problem.
Ich glaube, man hätte sich den Part
halt echt komplett sparen können.
Dü.
>> JOSH: Du hättest sie auch so reinstreichen können, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aber ich dachte, durch die Stärke
und durch das Einfrieren bindet sie eben noch.
Aber sie wollte nicht gebunden werden.
Aber ich hoffe trotzdem
– ich meine, wenn ihr auf Nummer sicher gehen wollt,
dann macht einfach eine Fruchteinlage,
so, wie ich es immer mache,
mit Johannisbeersaft und Agar Agar.
Da hätte ich auch gleich drauf kommen können.
Egal.
Es kann auch nicht immer alles glattlaufen bei mir.
Und ich hoffe einfach nur,
dass sich das gleich nicht verbindet beim Backen,
sondern dass es wirklich wie beim Lebkuchenherz
so eine schöne Füllung bleibt.
Jedenfalls probiere ich es jetzt einfach.
Wenn nicht, nenne ich das Video Schmecksperiment.
Also hier jetzt drübergeben vorsichtig.
Aber ich muss sagen, die Menge habe ich gut abgeschätzt.
On point!
Es ist immer gut, wenn man selber so
Kategorien benennt,
die so das eigene Fehlverhalten
rechtfertigen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und jetzt kommt die Tarte in den Backofen
und wird fertig gebacken.
Ich weiß noch nicht, wie viele Minuten.
Ich gucke einfach, wann es stockt,
und schreibe es euch dann in die App.
>> JOSH: Aber nicht, dass wir wieder
hier so einen Brand haben wie bei den Oreos.
>> SALLY: Und wenn wir einen Brand haben,
dann ist Sarah, die Reporterin, zur Stelle.
Oder?
>> SARAH: Ich bin schon bereit.
>> SALLY: Sarah ist schon bereit.
Aber Sarah braucht nicht kommen,
denn es wird alles gut laufen.
[Musik]
Jetzt zeige ich euch mal die Tarte.
Die ist jetzt fertig gebacken.
Aber guckt mal,
die ist noch ganz weich.
Und ich habe jetzt einfach den Ofen ausgemacht,
lasse die Tarte darin komplett abkühlen,
stelle sie dann noch mal
für mindestens zwei Stunden in den Kühlschrank
und dann stellen wir sie fertig und dekorieren sie.
Und das mache ich dann morgen,
damit sie einfach über Nacht im Kühlschrank steht.
Die Gingerbread-Männchen,
die werde ich jetzt noch dekorieren.
Ich meine, ich finde sie so schon echt schön.
Kann man auch so schon lassen.
Aber ich nehme jetzt noch ein bisschen Zuckerschrift
und werde einfach so die Augen, den Mund
ein bisschen ausdekorieren.
Das mache ich übrigens dann noch mal mit den Kids.
Denn ich glaube, da haben die echt mega Spaß dran.
[Musik]
Und damit ihr damit präziser arbeiten könnt,
ist eigentlich nur wichtig, dass die Spitze vorne
– dass ihr die dünn abschneidet.
Und dann lasst ihr die Cookies ein bisschen trocknen.
Und dann trocknet die Schrift auch schön an.
So. Den Mund jetzt rot oder
weiß?
Schon rot,
>> JOSH: Ja
>> SALLY: glaube ich.
Wie sieht so ein Gingerbread-Mann aus?
Ich probiere beides.
[Musik]
Oder die Knöpfe schwarz?
>> JOSH: Mh. Würde auch passen.
>> SALLY: Würde auch passen, nicht?
Ich glaube, ich mache noch welche mit schwarzen Knöpfen.
>> JOSH: Wie so ein kleiner Anzug dann.
>> SALLY: Ja!
Oh ja.
Aber die Augen schon weiß.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil das ist ja Zuckerschrift.
[Musik]
Meine Tarte war jetzt, wie gesagt, über Nacht im Backofen.
Komplett abgekühlt.
Ich habe sie jetzt doch nicht in den Kühlschrank gestellt.
Egal. Mache ich gleich.
Mir ist jetzt noch eingefallen,
dass ich ja die Tarte dekorieren will.
Und ich mache noch gezuckerte Cranberries,
weil ich die gerade noch
bei uns im Obst-/Gemüseladen gefunden habe.
Die könnt ihr auch schon im Vorfeld vorbereiten,
damit sie fertig sind.
Denn jetzt habe ich noch mal ein bisschen Wartezeit.
Aber ist egal.
Es ist ja nicht eilig.
Also ich brauche jetzt einfach ein bisschen Wasser,
– das sind 40 Gramm –
80 Gramm Zucker,
100 Gramm Cranberries
und dann noch mal 40 Gramm Zucker.
Und Cranberries,
die wachsen auch bei uns in Deutschland.
Vielleicht habt ihr sogar einen Cranberry-Baum.
Die sind megagesund,
zum Rohverzehr eher nicht so geeignet,
weil sie echt sehr,
ja, so bitter und sauer schmecken.
Aber ihr könnt sie zum Beispiel trocknen, dörren,
einkochen, einlegen, zu einer Soße verarbeiten.
Und gerade für die Blase ist sie wirklich super.
Wenn man zum Beispiel eine Blasenentzündung hat,
soll man viel Cranberries konsumieren.
Und deswegen finde ich,
das ist echt eigentlich ein richtig cooles Superfood.
Ich werde sie jetzt allerdings zuckern.
Deswegen sind da schon ein paar Kalorien mit dran.
Aber wir machen ja auch eine Süßigkeit, einen Kuchen.
Und ich werde die jetzt, wie gesagt, zuckern,
damit sie eine schöne Optik bekommen.
Und die restlichen, die ich habe,
die werde ich noch einkochen
oder dörren.
Nee, ich dörre sie einfach nur,
damit sie gesund sind fürs Müsli.
Ja.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach das Wasser und den Zucker.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier den Zuckersirup.
Wie gesagt, einfach nur kurz kochen lassen.
Wobei, ich lasse es noch ein bisschen einkochen.
Dann ist nämlich
weniger darin.
Außerdem wird dann der Zuckersirup
ein bisschen dickflüssiger
und kann sich besser um die Cranberries legen.
Schaut mal. Wenn so kleine Blubberbläschen
in eurem Sirup sind,
dann hat er die perfekte Konsistenz.
Daran erkennt man dann, dass er schön dickflüssig ist.
Und jetzt am besten direkt umfüllen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einen Emailleteller.
Denn der hat eine gute thermische Leitfähigkeit.
Der nimmt die Temperatur direkt an
und der Zuckersirup kühlt einfach am schnellsten ab.
Denn, wenn ihr da jetzt die Cranberries reingebt,
kann es nämlich passieren, dass sie aufplatzen,
und das will ich jetzt hier nicht.
So.
Müsste schon reichen.
Jetzt die Cranberries reingeben.
Schön verrühren,
damit sie wirklich komplett mit dem Zucker benetzt sind.
Aber das sieht ja schon mal superschön aus.
[Musik]
Die sind so schön!
Die erinnern mich auch so ein bisschen an
– heißen die Liebesapfel?
>> JOSH: Ah, stimmt. So kandierte.
>> SALLY: Kandierte Äpfel.
Aber ich möchte, dass die Cranberries
so eine eisige Schneeoptik bekommen.
Und deswegen lasse ich sie jetzt dörren.
Entweder gebt ihr sie jetzt in den Backofen
bei Heißluft oder Umluft
– Umluft ist besser, weil Umluft eher austrocknet –
und legt sie wirklich nebeneinander schön auf ein Backblech
und trocknet sie da bei ungefähr 60°C
oder ihr nehmt einfach den Dörrautomaten.
So mache ich das jetzt
und packe es da in den Dörrautomaten rein,
bis sie einfach schön durchgetrocknet sind.
Das Ganze dauert ungefähr eine Stunde.
Der Zucker kristallisiert so ein bisschen an der Oberfläche.
Und dann sieht es einfach aus wie kleine Wintercranberries.
Oh! So sind sie aber auch echt schön.
Ich packe die jetzt hier auf die Silikonmatte,
weil die Cranberries einfach recht klein sind
und ansonsten durch die Gitter
auch durchfallen würden, denke ich.
Und die, die ich dann nicht zuckern werde,
werde ich vorher in kochendes Wasser kurz legen,
damit die Schale aufplatzt
und die Cranberries dann ohne Zucker
schön durchtrocknen können für unser Müsli.
Also das sind dann eher so die gesunden ohne Zucker
und die hier sind die dekorativen für die Torte.
[Musik]
Weißt du, wenn manchmal Ela und Samira mich so fragen
und sagen: "Mama, dürfen wir ein Schleimrezept machen?"
und ich so: "Nee, wir spielen nicht mit Lebensmitteln
oder mit anderem, Rasierschaum oder Kleber",
aber eigentlich so mein Kind in mir sagt sich so:
"Mach einfach Schleim."
Kennst du das?
>> JOSH: Nee, aber ich kann es
ein bisschen nachvollziehen.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell? So wissenschaftlich betrachtet
lernen sie ja immerhin, was chemische Reaktionen sind.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, wir müssen Schleim machen.
Ich genieße es gerade.
Aber ich kann es halt nicht schneller machen, weil
das klebt halt.
[Musik]
Jetzt wird gedörrt.
Also, wie gesagt, entweder im Ofen bei 60°C Umluft
für eine Stunde ungefähr
oder ganz einfach im Dörrautomaten.
Die Cranberries sind jetzt gedörrt.
Die sind innen aber noch saftig.
Also die sind nicht komplett getrocknet.
Und so sehen sie jetzt erst mal aus.
Momentan sehen sie nicht gut aus, muss ich sagen.
Aber die haben jetzt so eine Restfeuchtigkeit.
Und die lege ich jetzt hier in den restlichen Zucker,
den ich ja noch übrig habe.
Und dann sind sie eben schön komplett einmal ummantelt.
Und es sieht halt echt aus, als wären sie so vereist,
verzuckert.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Das war ein kleiner...
Das war auch so ein kleiner Schreck,
wenn man dann drauf beißt
und die platzen dann so ein bisschen
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: und auf einmal explodiert so die Säure.
>> SALLY: Oh! Ich mag das.
>> JOSH: Aber cool.
>> SALLY: Megacool!
Aber ich muss sagen, die
– also ich dörre die restlichen noch für uns fürs Müsli,
so ohne Zucker.
Die sind halt dann richtig sauer.
Aber für so ein Müsli finde ich es okay.
Guckt mal. Die Tarte jetzt einfach rausnehmen.
Den Boden vorsichtig lösen.
Geht echt super.
Und jetzt werde ich sie fertig dekorieren.
Und zwar bestreue ich jetzt die Oberfläche mit Kakao.
Ich habe hier immer so eine kleine Dose mit Kakaoreis.
Ich habe hier einfach ungekochten Reis, also Reiskörner.
Und die nehmt ihr jetzt
– und Backkakao ist das noch.
Die kommen hier rein.
Denn dann kommt nicht auf einmal so viel Kakao raus,
weil der Reis einfach den Kakao weghält.
Und damit kann ich jetzt
so eine schöne matte Oberfläche erzeugen.
Und geschmacklich wird es halt dann
noch mal so ein bisschen herb.
Das mag ich gerne.
Das reicht schon.
Und drumherum lege ich jetzt die Cranberries.
Dann habe ich hier noch Rosmarin,
der jetzt geschmacklich nicht passt, aber optisch
einfach so ein bisschen an Tannenzweige erinnert.
Ich habe meine Kekse.
Und hier habe ich noch so kleine Gold- und Silbersterne.
Die sind essbar,
also könnt ihr auch gerne immer als Deko benutzen.
Und das lege ich jetzt einfach schön als Kranz obendrauf.
[Musik]
Wie so ein Adventskranz.
Ich glaube, ich nehme ein paar Goldsterne,
aber nur wenige.
[Musik]
Fertig!
Die Tarte kann probiert werden.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Du musst in unsere Mitte.
>> SALLY: Wir haben nur zwei Gabeln. Hol schnell noch eine.
Schnell.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Ja, hattet ihr also zwei Gabeln nur.
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> JOSH: Das merke ich mir.
>> SALLY: Sarah hat ihr eigene vergessen.
>> SARAH: Die Sally und ich essen mit einer Gabel.
>> JOSH: Das merke ich mir.
>> SALLY: Sarah hat ihr eigene vergessen.
>> SARAH: Sally und ich essen doch immer von einer.
Warum holst du große Gabeln?
Das sind Kuchengabeln!
>> SALLY: Ich mag...
>> JOSH: Leute, das merke ich mir.
>> SALLY: Ich mag aber große Gabeln,
auch beim Kuchenessen.
Ich weiß nicht warum, aber ich mag es halt.
>> JOSH: Krass! Nee.
>> SALLY: Ich mag nicht so kleine Gabeln.
>> JOSH: Hä? Kuchengabel.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> JOSH: Für was ist das sonst existent?
>> SALLY: Kinder.
>> SARAH: Hä?
>> JOSH: Was?!
>> JOSH: Nee.
>> SARAH: Das ist zum Essen und das...
>> SALLY: Ich esse voll gern
– also so, wenn ich serviere, anrichte,
klar, lege ich auch eine kleine dazu.
Aber ich liebe so eine große Gabel.
>> SARAH: Weil du dann mehr drauf hast?
>> SALLY: Ich bin halt ein großer Mensch.
Okay, du bist größer.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Dem Josh ist das egal.
Der isst auch von kleinen Gabeln.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Unser Song.
>> SARAH: Wir können jetzt nicht dem Josh zu nahe gehen.
>> SALLY: Doch. Dürfen wir unseren Tarte-Song singen?
>> JOSH: Beobachte ich halt so und trinke Kaffee
mit meiner kleinen Gabel.
>> SARAH: Ich will auch Kaffee trinken!
>> SALLY: Ich auch!
Oh!
>> JOSH: Und wer singt dann?
>> SALLY: Wir.
>> SARAH: Du.
>> SALLY: Du.
>> JOSH: Ich singe
nicht.
Können wir jetzt mal probieren?
Ich habe Hunger.
>> SARAH: Ich würde ihn auch gern essen.
Ich muss zugeben, ich habe gerade Fotos gemacht
und dann mache ich immer eine
– weil ich klug bin,
mache ich eine Gabel runter,
um ein Stück zu fotografieren
in Nahaufnahme.
Und dann muss ich die danach essen.
Das heißt, ich habe das schon probiert.
>> SALLY: Seht ihr? Das mit der Marmelade hat geklappt.
>> SARAH: Mega!
>> SALLY: Da unten ist eine Marmeladenschicht einfach.
>> JOSH: Können wir das so in die Kamera halten?
>> SALLY & SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY & JOSH: Oh!
>> SARAH: Meins ist auseinandergebrochen.
>> SALLY: Oh, da sieht echt gut aus.
Kannst du das mal in die Kamera halten so?
>> JOSH: In die da. Hier.
Dahin.
>> SARAH: Muss ich vorlaufen?
>> SALLY: Nee, hier.
>> JOSH: Nee, das geht schon.
Ich glaube, das sieht man so ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Toll!
>> JOSH: Mmh!
Okay.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Hm. So habe ich vorhin auch geguckt.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> SARAH: Also ich muss sagen,
es ist hundertmal besser, als ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
>> JOSH: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Also ich habe es mir nicht so...
>> SALLY: Ich habe es mir auch nicht so gut vorgestellt.
>> SARAH: Weil ich bin eigentlich...
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Erstaunlich, wie das an diese
Schokoherzen erinnert,
>> SALLY: Gell?
wo so gefüllt sind mit diesem...
>> SARAH: Davon bin ich nämlich eigentlich gar kein Fan,
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SARAH: von so Schokoherzen mit Füllung.
>> JOSH: Die schmecken halt zu industriell,
vor allem die Schokolade da drin.
>> SALLY: Ja, das stimmt.
>> SARAH: Woah! Aber der Kuchen ist...
>> SALLY: Oh, und die Marmelade da drin!
>> JOSH: Uh!
Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte gerade sagen, der Rand ist härter.
>> JOSH: Ja.
Mach du das mit deiner großen Gabel.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh! Die kleinen Ministernchen sind so süß.
>> JOSH: Warte kurz.
Kurz eine andere...
Ha ja,
du Bauer, ey.
>> SARAH: Ich muss sagen,
>> JOSH: Mit dem...
>> SARAH: der obere Teil erinnert mich ein bisschen
an Mississippi Mud Pie. Kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Schmeckt schon...
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Schmeckt schon ähnlich.
>> SALLY: Also ich muss
>> JOSH: Ich tu das Bäumchen weg.
>> SALLY: tatsächlich zugeben, dass ich nicht gedacht hätte,
dass das mit dem Gingerbread-Teig,
mit dem Lebkuchenteig so gut klappt.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Weil ich dachte eigentlich,
der ist dann wirklich hart oder fest.
Aber der ist ja super.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Esst mal noch so eine Cranberry dazu.
>> SARAH: Einzeln oder mit Kuchen?
>> SALLY: Boah!
Wie die so cool aufplatzt!
>> JOSH: Übel, gell?
>> SALLY: Wie so ein Bonbon.
>> JOSH: Passt voll gut dazu.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
Wie die nimm2.
>> JOSH & SALLY: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oh, lecker!
>> SARAH: Oh! War das Werbung?
>> SALLY: Egal.
Unbezahlt.
>> JOSH: Ja. Die kennt jeder aus der Kindheit, ganz ehrlich.
>> SARAH: Ja, das stimmt.
>> SALLY: Oh, lecker!
>> JOSH: Oh ja!
>> SALLY: Also ich muss sagen,
das ist, glaube ich, mit Abstand
eine der besten Tartes,
die ich je gebacken habe.
>> JOSH: In der Tarte.
[Tusch]
>> SALLY: Wir kommen mit dem Tarte-Ort-Spruch
– Tarte-Spruch.
>> SARAH: Tarte-Ort.
Ja, der war super.
>> JOSH: Tarte-Ort.
>> SALLY: Falls ihr also auch
Lust auf diese leckere Tarte bekommen habt,
dann probiert sie gerne mal aus.
Das Rezept findet ihr auf sallys-blog.de
oder in meiner App.
Da gibt es auch alle Rezepte kostenlos.
Und ihr könnt sie euch speichern,
einen Einkaufskorb
– also einen Einkaufszettel erstellen.
Ihr könnt den Einkaufszettel per WhatsApp verschicken.
Ihr könnt die Zutaten hoch- und runterrechnen.
Und ihr könnt einfach alle Rezepte ausprobieren.
Also backt sie gerne nach,
ladet ein Foto hoch.
Und wir sehen uns wieder das nächste Mal.
Tschüss!
>> SARAH: Darf ich was YouTubermäßiges sagen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Macht die Glocke an.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Thank you
>> SALLY & SARAH: for baking this tart!
>> SARAH: 'cause this tart has just made me
fatter!
>> SALLY: Stronger!
>> SARAH: Stronger?
>> SALLY: Happier!
>> JOSH: Reimt sich eigentlich fart auf tart?
>> SALLY: Happier.
This tart
>> SARAH: Fatter.
>> SALLY: has making me happier!
>> SARAH: Was machst du für einen Move?
Happier!
>> SALLY: Ich habe es gefühlt.
>> JOSH: Ihr könnt das machen mit dem Singen.
>> SARAH: Das ist so ein Boyband-Move.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich weiß. Das war so ein
>> SARAH: Happier!
Boah! Ich habe es erkannt.
>> SALLY: Backstreet-Boys-Move.
>> SARAH: Oh, warte! Wir drehen uns um.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Aber erst bei happier.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SALLY & SARAH: Thank you for baking this tart!
'cause this tart
>> SARAH: had just made me happier!
>> SALLY: Happier!
>> SARAH: Boah! Du hast es richtig verkackt gerade.
>> SALLY: Ich wusste den Text nicht mehr.
Noch mal.
>> SALLY & SARAH: Thank you for baking this tart!
'cause this tart had just made me happier!
[Musik]